what's up everyone I'm Mike McCarty we
are here at Gamescom 2016 in Cologne
Germany
I'm here with Tamar Hussain who just
played what sounds like a crazy game yet
vampire
made by don't know dense Ayman who you
may know as the guys behind or life is
strange but it's not got that much in
common with it that's what people most
probably know the most for it's closer
to remember me the game they did before
that which is published by Capcom
there's still some elements of life is
strange stuff like and we focus on
characters and narrative and dialogue
decision is by definitely feels like
more of an action driven game which is
it seems like they're trying to take in
some learnings about storytelling from
life estranged and build that into this
new game but yeah it's it's a it's
interesting experience from what I can
tell so far I'm not quite sold on it but
they've got some hooks in there that are
quite like so like a strange and a super
weird narrative is that kind of the case
here with vampire it's it feels like the
same kind of makes it kind of initially
seem quite simple it's a you know you
play this character called dr. Jonathan
Reed he's been to war he's a doctor he's
figured out stuff about blood
transplants and that kind of stuff and
returns to London where there's a
Spanish flu epidemic and also vampires
they go hand in hand
yeah and just conveniently he's you know
his expert on blood he gets bitten by a
vampire and like oh man I got it okay
yeah so exactly that is peak irony for
vampires but yeah so it's all about kind
of I'm not sure what the actual main
quest is but it seems like he's just
dealing with the aftermath of being a
vampire and this like elements of the
city which is poor to how you play the
game so like it has a population and
different districts that takes place in
London so you go to places like
Whitechapel and that kind of stuff and
the key of what I saw was how your
actions within the city influence your
surroundings so you are a human and also
a vampire there was a hint that they you
may be some sort of daywalker but they
don't confirm that all it was kind of
like maybe maybe not but
you have you need to feed but you're
also trying to be a good guy I know I
should feel something so why don't I
what does it mean that I'm dead too
what's troubling you so much Jonathan
lady Osprey what are you doing here
the main focus seems to be on balancing
being a good person and a vampire and
the kind of vampiric side of you is
always trying to pull you into being a
bad person
you have to feed on the denizens of the
city but how are you kind of do that is
up to you it never tells you who you can
and can't kill everyone in the city is
open to be you know feeds fed on by you
but they give you enough information on
each person for you to figure out
whether this person is a good person or
a bad person but that doesn't
necessarily like make it easier because
they have relationships they're quite
localized it's not like you're feeding
into a greater story it's like for
example during our demo we had this guy
who seemed like a bit of a no-goodnik
and we would just want to kind of like
speak to him about his son but like I
said he's got a son and the son is ill
he's a bad person and he acts like a bit
of a terrible like drunky type but like
you need to think about do you want to
eat him straight away or do you want to
kind of like be nice to him so you can
get the information out of the sea about
the kids so you can speak to the kid and
they have like tropes like for example
you need to be invited in before you can
do something so you have the dialog
system where you've got to try and keep
it sweet with them for as long as
possible until you get the information
and then you can use like a vampiric
power like mesmerize to get him to go
into the shadows where you can feed on
him and that kind of stuff so the thing
that's really interesting about this
game for me is how they build how they
leverage what they achieved and learn
from life is strange into a game that's
closer to you know the game before life
is strange remember me which kind of
wasn't critically-acclaimed or sold
really well it's gonna be interesting to
see how they figure that stuff out and
whether it is gonna be like you can see
that all life is strange has improved
their storytelling it seems like they've
got a cool idea but whether it turns out
to be you know something exceptional
that kind of estate taken in by the pop
culture in gaming and I
kind of stuff just a matter of time I
reckon co-op you know does it have a
release date and if so widens it release
don't believe it does
I may be lying just check gamespot.com
there's go all the hot release dates
alright all there but like we'll have an
interview with one of their guys from
the development team hopefully soon but
yeah well that's vampire for more coming
out of Gamescom 2016 stay tuned and
GameSpot will have news impressions and
previews throughout the week